right subaru is the perfect car for your
summer adventures this year
and they have all the accessories you
need to stay safe and comfortable
so summer is right around the corner and
we have got
subaru accessories that will get you
ready to go to the great outdoors
and you know i tell you what this right
up here is amazing
this is a rooftop tent you can open it
up and you can sleep in there
and you know if that's not your cup of
tea we can have a rack up there for
kayaks or we can have a rack up there
for bikes
or you know we can just accessorize this
whole thing for your pet
i mean it's amazing what we have
available for your subaru
what's cool about a subaru is you can go
your garage
get in your car and you can head out to
the great outdoors
you don't have to go rent something
subarus are amazing they have
symmetrical all-wheel drive
that's class exclusive nobody has
symmetrical all-wheel drive i have to
explain that
but they also have 8.7 inches of ground
clearance
that means you can go off the beaten
path and you'll have the the clearance
you need to protect the undercarriage
you know what we have a feature called
x-mode x-mode
is advanced all-wheel drive and it will
help you go with just mud and snow
and and and dirt and maybe even get over
some little rocks i
i don't want to encourage you to go too
far out there but it is amazing the
capability
and the safety that subaru offers two of
the features that subaru owners put
their faith and trust in
are eyesight accident avoidance system
it's an amazing system
that will give you emergency braking
capability it will keep you in your lane
and also if you're on a long drive you
can set the cruise and it's adaptive it
will
maintain that safe speed wherever the
traffic is going or stopping
the other feature is called starlink and
it is the connected safety
and security services that you get and
it's connected literally to a satellite
and it will help you if you need help
you can press the button you can ask
questions
it'll also notify you if your car needs
service
it's just an amazing thing to have in
your vehicle you know at subaru
we love the earth and subaru has got a
partnership
with lee canyon what a great place to go
during the summer or the winter
and it's interesting because you can go
there with your subaru and you have
exclusive
subaru parking up there they have signs
for you and everything
they have lift rides they've got all
kind of activities for the family
and they've enhanced the the restaurants
and and the
options that you have just for a great
weekend you know at subaru
we love our community and one of the
things that we're doing this month
is because it's military appreciation
month we're taking fifty dollars from
every vehicle that is purchased or
leased
and we're donating it to the uso nevada
and in our service department we're
taking three dollars from every oil
change
and donating that to uso nevada so
summertime is coming
and your subaru is ready to go are you
ready is it going to be the beach
is it going to be the mountains are you
going to the desert where are you going
to take your subaru
it's ready to go with you i'm ready for
all of that visit subaru with
lasvegas.com or give them a call
at 702-495-2 remember their special
offer here too
zero percent financing on select 2021
models for
well-qualified applicants